Now me and Tim, me and Tim went on the, as cruise together last year.
You can't make it this year because of previous thing you have,
you have other work things you can't mess. Yeah.
But I really just canceled it. Cause I don't want to go.
Let's just be honest with you because you're a wild kid. Yeah.
You're your treat for humanity. I was trying to just spit it for you. I got it.
I'm just going to be open and honest. I don't want to go. The fans are weird.
I'm going to get Legionnaires' disease. I don't want to lose my wifi.
I got a kid at home and big Jay Oakerson creeped me out. He's going to love it.
He's going to love it. He goes, every year he was at,
was he on with us last year though? But he likes that one pant leg up.
He loves it. Yeah. He loves it. But tell the people I wanted your perspective.
Did I get away Sean Chan for that? Yeah. Well here's the problem.
I knew there was a problem because you meet it. The cruise.
Terminal, we'll go. We all go into new Orleans and we meet.
Cruise terminal.
And many of the people that were taking the cruise had decided to bring food and
beverages with them automatically. I knew this was what you can't do,
right? The, well, here's the thing. You can't do it in certain cases.
But I knew this was a group. So bringing food and drinks on vacation with you,
that's a certain type of person. You know, that's a certain type of person.
Let's be honest. That's a disgusting person. It's not for me that much.
Not for me. So I saw people dragging coolers, all kinds of stuff. Now we're,
we're cruising into the middle of the ocean,
but this boat is the size of a mall. It really is.
So you'd imagine there'd be food on it. But these people were like,
just in case that runs low. I have snacks. Yeah. So for the room,
one of the ladies said to me, I swear to God. She goes,
I have brought snacks for the room. I said for the room,
there's a 24 hour buffet. Give you an idea.
These people didn't want to be caught in the room.
Hungry. They didn't want artists are talking about it.
There's not. If, if there's even a little space in their stomach,
even a little bubble there, I mean,
you see, it looks like you're at, you looks like you're at a fare,
watching a go-cart. It looks like a go-cart festival.
Just medieval times on the boat. There's scooters everywhere.
These people are here. It is. Let me tell you right now,
it is crazy because I'm a big dude.
And I understand that there's it's, you know,
there's a whole fat activist movement where people are like, you know,
you should be fat. And I never was into that. I was always like, I eat too.
I eat too much. I should, I should watch.
I can't go to sleep til four in the morning to my food. This is not good.
This is a bad thing. I'm slowly killing myself.
When I used to do cocaine for years, I never did cocaine.
And thought about starting a blog on everybody. Get, start doing up your nose.
It's great. Everybody should lay in bed till 4:00 AM. And with their throat,
all scratch. I feel discriminated.
Against. When someone said, Hey, you might want to quit.
Cocaine. And my gear oppressing me. Yeah.
So I think food is like a drug.
You see people on this boat that is their
lifestyle is like, they're like that.
And they're not even. And I hate to say like, they're not even fat off,
good food. You got fat off Pringles and TV,
your TV, dinner, fat, your RBS fat, your buffet fat.
Like you're not, you've never even had a good thing, right?
They would come to New York. They would have a stroke.
If they ate any of this food, they'd be dead in a week.
They don't even know like this exists.
They've never had proper tomato sauce or anything.
These are Domino's people and they're on the boat.
And let me tell you right now, man,
the kids are like little cinnamon buns.
The kids are huge. Yeah. The kids.
Are big. The pool is the size of a postage stamp.
There's about two or three people that could fit in this pool at once.
Maybe one person and her two children and the pool is completely full.
I thought they would have a big pool water slide.
There's no Waterslide because everybody keeps getting stuck enough to plunge
them out. Um, there was a buffet, 24 hours too. And the,
and the boat, they want to prevent an outbreak of disease.
So when you walk into the boat, that's a nice, friendly reminder.
Every time it's a Filipino guy,
because everybody who works in the boat lives in the Philippines.
This is the fact that all the cruise industry lives in the Philippines.
You never see them when they're not working.
They make them live in a pipe in the middle of the ship.
There were allowed out once a day. They're always working. You never see them.
He got us talking about, I go, you never, there's no breaks.
You never see two crews, employees being like, you know,
you don't remember the last crew. None of that hard at work.
harder work with it gone. Yeah. I don't know where they are.
Maybe they go overboard, but you never see them. They go back to the pipe.
So this one, dude, he would just stand in the front of the buffet, go washy,
washy. And he would spray your hands. And I'm talking about,
this was not hand sanitizer. This was like a poison,
like killing everything on you get hurt when he sprayed your hands.
Like it was like ammonia that you had to rub your hands.
You rubbed the layer of skin off your hands because everybody was so they were
so nervous about cause it's a Petri dish. They're like,
we don't want these people spread.
Cause if there are cases where like 1800 people get sick and then the party's
over the Legionnaires' disease virus, then party's over.
And what these cruise lines do,
carnival cruise will abandon these in the middle of the ocean.
They don't give a. Cause none of these people are rich.
None of these people have lawyers. They know they're not doing anything.
So Carnival's like, leave them out there. And. Sometimes there's like a,
the electrical critical down on one of these faults or carnivals, like whatever,
just let the military of whatever conscience figure it out.
They don't give a because these people are disposable.
Carnival knows these don't have a lawyer not going to come.
This isn't a river cruise going down the Daniels, you know,
these are gonna deal with it. It is what it is. Half of them won't notice,
you know? Wow. Yeah. That's fun. See, but that's what I'm saying.
Like that's why no it's bad. All that stuff I got. If I'm being honest with you,
what it started with made me make a bad excuse.
It started with me and Yonis in there before the thing took
off. We knew I, yeah, you want it to get off before it light? It won't be there.
Yeah. Like if, if they would have come up to you and said, listen,
you guys can get off. If you want. You're not going to get paid,
but you can get off. You have gone to be honest. You're also New York.
Conch is kind of the term. So a lot of people love it.
A lot of our peers love it.
They let me tell you right now they adore it and that's okay.
There's nothing wrong with that. They were born in other places. This is,
I guess it's exciting for them because of that. Yeah. It's very exciting.
The boat is, isn't a boat. Big. Get me out.
Get me away from you and your thought process. Um, I get on a boat,
honest gets on the boat.
We start looking around and we start saying to ourselves,
we're looking at all the P the mouth breathers.
And they have them in like a FEMA tent. They haven't been a big cruise terminal,
I think, got their food and the potato chips.
And then they'll start lumbering on this thing. And we're like,
it just hits us immediately. Oh,
we're about to go into the middle of the ocean with these people, with Walmart.
And that's exactly what it is. That's what it is. And there's nowhere to gut.
There's nowhere to go and listen, it's not a tropical pack. It's cold.
You can out in the middle of the ocean. You think it's like a tropical paradise.
It's people, weren't hoodies. It's kind of windy. It's not that sunny.
You dock at a, like, uh,
like a weird sandbar that Royal Caribbean and carnival cruise bought.
And it turned into Costa Maya, Mexico, which doesn't exist.
And it's these guys that are dressed up like conquistadores and pirates.
And these idiots, these fat idiots, they sell them jewelry.
There's a 24 hour news channel in your little. And by the way,
the accommodations you have, you stay in like a little,
I don't know how some of those people fit in those cabins. They don't,
they shut the door on their fat, like tuck.
It it's like the way that I fit into a jacket.
They fit into the cabin there in the cabin. They put on a channel.
The channel is 24 hour. Uh, what you can buy when you get to this Island.
And it's just some guy going, Hey,
I've been in the cruise and jewelry industry for 25 years and you go,
that's not a thing. There is no cruise. And he goes,
the deals you're going to get. When we land in Costa, Maya are amazing.
And he starts showing you these bracelets and earrings.
And then what happens is he fat people get off the boat and they go to these
little jewelry stands and they're all like kiosks on the beach. And then they,
they jam these necklaces around these fat ladies necks and they pay money.
And then they get back on the boat and it is, it is a mess. And by the way,
they take you, you get on, like you get in a cab. When you go to a resort,
they take great pains to disguise how the rest of the area is the best part.
They pick you up and they take you right to the resort. They don't around.
When you go on a cruise and you land in the Island.
If you want to go to the restaurant or the beach or something like that,
they got to drive you through the rest of the Island before you get there.
So you get in this little like golf cart,
that seats about eight people and you drive through, I am not kidding. Hellish,
third world. Hellscape where there's guys with no shoes,
chasing roosters for dinner. They're sitting,
everybody's 400 pounds. There's people playing the xylophone on their ribs,
wasting away on the side of the road. Like there's people that would kill you.
If they were hung, they're emaciated. They lack the strength, the plunge,
a knife in your throat. They would, if they could,
and you wouldn't blame them either. I'd be like.
If I was starving and they just caught it around fat people, it is,
it is the craziest thing. And I just said to myself, I'm like, how?
And then you start listening to people around you. And they're like, well,
we took carnival last year. And I'm like, Oh, this is a thing that people do.
And they enjoy it. And it's like, I don't even want to be part of.
It's just such a mix because it's so true. He says that they like,
there's this where you dock this little area.
That's just completely commercialized tourist with the cookies doors.
And then you just travel a little farther out. You're in a 10th world country.
And what we do is we just show up in this moving mall with all the
food in the world.
Yeah. And if we just took that food and gave it to the people,
they'd be happy when we go, no, we're getting off. We're buying a key chain.
And then we're getting back on us and taking the food away.
People think you're having a cultural experience. Is Fatma people from Ohio,
walking around eating churros, pointing at fake,
like what do they call those statues? Uh, the, um, the, the totem poles,
totem poles are fake. They're not all thick.
They were built three years ago by Royal Caribbean and carnival cruise line.
And this fat idiot. You're like, Oh, it's Mexican chocolate. They're boiling.
Hershey's these don't know I'm not eating churros. And they all, and here's,
what's most disturbing. This is I think what disturbed me. And you're honest,
the mouse, this is what was the most dystopian about it.
Everybody thought it was great.
Everybody enjoyed it so much that you went so crazy. You're like, am I wrong?
They just started realizing how over we are.
You know,
you realize that it's really is over because everyone thought it was a great
time and it was raining and cold. And so, okay. Cause that was my question.
So like, cause like it's February right now, you guys have to say in February,
other than that, we had a great time. Other than that, it was fine.
I understand leaving the Florida. I understand leaving the ports.
It's going to be cold, but you're saying even when you get to Mexico,
it's still cold there.